the city of hamtramck puts a new face on
representative government in america
for a century it was a polish-american
enclave in michigan surrounded by the
city of detroit
now a wave of new immigrants from yemen
bangladesh pakistan has eroded the
dominance of warsaw in 2013 the city
became majority muslim
a call to prayer echoes past the gothic
spires of catholic churches and the
aromas of poland mingle with the sense
of the east
this year for the first time the mayor
and all six members of its city council
are muslim the only entirely muslim city
government in the united states mayor
ahmer ghalib says hamtramck's tale is
the latest evolution of the story of
america the american dream is is a life
and
the doors of opportunities are open for
everyone
and
i came as an immigrant
in high school i was
after i finished 11th grade in yemen
and
did all my schoolings here and now i'm
the mayor of the city
the mayor echoes a similar sentiment to
that of another barrier-breaking
politician who came under fire for his
religion before becoming president in
1960. because i am a catholic
and no catholic has ever been elected
president
the real issues in this campaign have
been obscured i believe in an america
where religious intolerance will someday
end
for all men and all churches are treated
as equals
downtown hamtramck bridges its past with
its present with the polish-american
congress right next to a bangladeshi
business what's changed is it's now just
seven percent polish and majority muslim
the changing face of the city hasn't
come without controversy there's the
people who want to be like oh they're
going to bring sharia law and all the
women are going to be forced to cover
and women aren't going to be able to
drive anymore all of those things right
amanda jakowski spans the cultural gap
here a polish-american who converted to
islam we said baptia because it's
grandma and polish and this is when she
lived in hamtramck she says the issues
here are neither religious nor cultural
they're the kind of problems of many
cities like a high poverty rate in the
united states we have that separation of
church and state we have those
principles of making sure that we're
representing everyone and we're not
bringing religion into that sphere in
terms of the way that decisions get made
but processes happen there's not that
much of a difference city leaders are
hoping the newfound attention might
bring tourism and commerce to the home
of america's newest wave of immigrants
john hendren al jazeera hamtramck
michigan